55 degrés Celsius c'est la température
que la Vallée de la Mort en Californie a
officiellement atteint ce dimanche 16
juillet le mercure bat également des
records en Asie le Japon est en alerte
chaleur dans la moitié des préfectures
du pays touchant des dizaines de
millions de personnes 36 degrés à Tokyo
de 39 à 45 degrés dans plusieurs régions
chinoises malgré cette fournaise les
touristes et voyageurs du monde entier
sont fiers de prendre la pose devant le
thermomètre
en Europe c'est une semaine suffoquante
qui s'annonce 39 degrés en Roumanie plus
de 40 au sud de l'Espagne et jusqu'à 48
degrés en Sardaigne depuis ce week-end
la guerre semble clairement déclaré
entre Jean-Luc Mélenchon et le CRIF il
est devenu l'Allier objectif du
rassemblement national par ses outrances
parce que en se comportant ainsi il
donne le sentiment que l'extrême droite
deviendrait la réponse légitime aux
sous-trans de l'extrême gauche aussitôt
le principal intéressé a répondu sur
Twitter voici ce qu'il dit le président
du CRIF utilise la cérémonie à la
mémoire des victimes de la RA Duvel DIF
pour par la police française pour me
prendre à parti abject l'extrême droite
n'a plus de limite et je trouve
qu'utiliser une cérémonie comme celle-ci
pour s'en prendre à une organisation
politique et à la France insoumise de
manière générale je trouve que c'est un
digne vous auriez pu l'écrire vous ce
tweet assimilez le CRIF et l'extrême
droite non je n'assumais pas du tout le
cri fait à l'extrême droite c'est lui
qui pratique le rayon laser pour dire
qui est fréquentable qui ne l'est pas en
réalité je pense qu'il s'ennuie
terriblement et que pour la première
fois il n'a pas de mandat et qu'il
essaie de discipliner ses troupes pour
qu'il le suivent comme des moutons de
Panurge derrière toutes ces outrances il
y a du de l'antisémitisme partout en
France est-ce que ça
je vous dis je
n'assimule pas le CRIF à l'extrême
droite d'aucune manière j'aurais préféré
que cette journée de commémoration
dommage elle soit effectivement
consacrée à la commémoration et à
l'hommage et pas des manœuvres
politiciennes liée à la prise de drogue
et d'alcool qui ont poussé le
gouvernement instaurer un nouveau délit
d'homicide routier il remplace celui
d'homicide involontaire quand on prend
la voiture on a vu ou qu'on a pris de
l'alcool et bien on est inconscient
quelque part on est inconscient de faire
courir ce risque à soi-même et aux
autres et quelque part c'est
effectivement un homicide dès lors qu'on
va tuer quelqu'un sur la route il faut
le reconnaître comme tel donc c'est en
réponse à cette demande que le missile
involontaire par conducteur va être
requalifiée en homicide routier c'est un
tout décès intervenu notamment suite à
un feu grillé un excès de vitesse mais
aussi à la prise de stupéfiants ou
d'alcool un changement de terme surtout
symbolique qui n'alourdit pas les peines
encourue l'idée de manière générale avec
ce débat notamment c'est de durcir les
règles tout simplement pour ne pas les
peines ce sera un des points de
discussion parce que quand on parle de
ce genre d'adaptation ça va au Parlement
ensuite donc il y a plusieurs
initiatives parlementaires qui ont déjà
été prises il n'y a pas de changement
aujourd'hui une peine encourue pour
homicide involontaire c'est 50 prisons
75000 euros d'un manque d'amende peine
encourue pour homicide involontaire mais
souvent prise d'alcool ou de stupéfiants
on parle de 10 ans de prison de 105000
euros d'amende il y a eu 358 personnes
qui ont été décorées vendredi alors
souvent on dit c'est les copains d'abord
il faudrait ressortir la liste complète
pour voir qui a été décoré mais il y a
une des décorations qui a vraiment fait
polémique c'est celle de Patrick
pouyanetic cet homme est responsable
d'écocide dans le monde quand on est en
train de suffoquer en Europe le seul
truc que trouve à faire le gouvernement
c'est de décorer un de ses premiers
responsables c'est à dire le PDG de
l'entreprise totale cet homme est un
tiers en France cet homme est dangereux
il voulait la Légion d'Honneur non
seulement je lui retire la Légion
d'honneur mais en plus je regarde
comment l'inculper pour ecocide
finalement on voit la Légion d'honneur
est plus que une forme de de de boys
band d'amis d'Emmanuel Macron à qui on
octroie à qui l'octroi voilà à ses amis
je pense que c'est malheureux la presse
britannique pleure aussi Jane Bee en
évoquant plus que l'artiste que nous
connaissons
ignicone de la mode